well where do we start with the drama
last night Mike you know sister your
typical Laker game tomorrow odom showing
up for the first time since dating
strokes last October Johnny Manziel in
the crowd Lakers actually winning a game
which hasn't happened a lot and of
course the big the big thing DeAngelo
Russell nick Young an unbelievable day
just a typical day to laker land right
nothing new nothing too crazy crazy what
was the locker room like it was kind of
political you know is very diplomatic we
talk to Julius Randle with this big
game-winning shot last night against the
team by the way Miami that really needed
a victory to stay in the chase for third
place in the Eastern Conference and
everyone to talk to Julius about the
angelo and nick Young he kind of chose
the diplomatic route saying I support
both those guys Jordan Clarkson similar
sentiment both those guys are my
brothers you know that one's trying to
be diplomatic that I just don't know how
it's going to end up it's a very bizarre
situation to say the least yeah because
I'm looking and I guess you can look at
a bigger picture here of free agents
wanting to play there what's the future
of I think you got a nucleus there with
with Clarkson Randall and DeAngelo
Russell but I don't know who else
survives this so can you look at big
picture because small picture is they
just play out the rest of the season
you're not going to the playoffs but
what does this mean in the offseason for
the team and future teammates Dan that
is a huge question I mean the Lakers are
going to have about 50 55 million
dollars to spend on pace to have more
than anyone else in the league
especially with the big jump in the
salary cap coming up and struggled the
last couple years without any questions
about character on their team they're
all 47 in their last free agents outs
including their own guys Dwight Howard
and Gasol obviously Carmelo Anthony
LaMarcus Aldridge that meeting did not
go so well last summer and there were no
questions about team character at all
this summer you know I think they'll
have to pay guys a little bit more
you may have to maybe like a nic batum
or they might go dr. DeMar DeRozan just
to be able to try to get them to play
for the Lakers and they will be able to
I'm not saying that one correlates with
the other they have to pay more to kind
of bribe guys to play Angela but they're
going to have enough money that someone
will take their money and they will be
safe you would think they'll be better
next year although that's why I said a
year ago as well on that turn out to be
accurate what about Kevin Durant it
seems like every other day there's a new
report or speculation of where he could
end up and I just saw one today we're a
don't rule out the Lakers well you can't
rule out the Lakers but can you know get
a meeting with him I can't see how they
don't get to sit down with Kevin Durant
but if he wants to win a championship
this obviously is not the team 16
victories and here we are one day from
April just an unbelievable bad season
for them almost done I compared to
continually tumbling into the abyss and
I just don't see why he would want to
come to this franchise because they're
really far from a championship right now
who's going to coach this team next year
that's a really good question you know
Byron Scott as tumultuous as yesterday
was for the Lakers it turn out to be a
pretty good day for him he will not say
this publicly I might be sure he's
thinking that right now but he's had all
this tough love with the young guys
throughout the entire season been
criticized for it you know what are you
pat riley without the championship
roster another thing but this this
activity this behavior by their young
guys D'Angelo Russell in particular kind
of justifies Byron's tough love
throughout this entire season he's been
very critical ultimately over the last
six months of what these guys need to do
on and off the court and this might have
bought him some time maybe Laker fans
are saying okay everything he's been
doing this season there's a reason for
it if these guys are going to behave
like this off the court I know D'Angelo
Russell did meet with the media did
anybody ask him how the video actually
got leaked yeah he claims that he does
not know he seemed pretty insistent
about it he kept bringing up he kind of
kept ending his cell by
with it a couple times no matter what
the question was it seemed he seems
pretty insistent that he has no idea out
weeds out no there was a snapchat report
earlier in the day yesterday but the
video was too long for a typical
snapchat which is about 10 seconds so
unless D'Angelo has some special
snapchat access that none of us have I
think he probably just shot a video on
his phone probably texted it to a couple
guys you know a couple friends maybe and
then maybe this happened a couple months
ago this video was not shot two days ago
or even two weeks ago and maybe one of
his guys just recently had his home his
phone hacked or maybe he went behind the
Angels back and sold it to a gossip
website a few days ago look at us
talking social media look at you talking
snapchat Mike can you believe though
that you of all the stories you've
covered and you covered a lot with the
Lakers where does this one rank it's
pretty high up there when I took over
the beat in 2004 remember Karl Malone
got in a verbal spat with Vanessa Bryant
Kobe's wife and Vanessa kind of accused
him of hunting Mexican women and I'm
like what is this what is going on and
and this is this is right up there with
that you know just a wild wild 12 years
I've had covering the Lakers and this is
definitely the wildest story of the
season you know it's funny Dan Latin
Lakers kind of trunk themselves with
these crazy stories just last week a
woman accused Jordan Clarkson and nick
Young of verbally harassing her while
they were both in their cars while both
parties were in their cars in Hollywood
and you like this is this is odd this is
bizarre and nick Young and Jordan
Clarkson kind of did a side by side
standing up news conference in the laker
locker room last week and then this
comes along and kind of trumps all that
like what's next what's next week gonna
break you know you just have no idea if
the lakers kobe but if the lakers get
the number one pick was the Kobe
farewell tour successful yeah I'd say
number one or number two I mean Ben
Simmons is incredible obviously you've
got Brandon Ingram at Duke I think
you'll also be a really really good NBA
player they don't want to fall to three
because you know Brees kind of the wild
wild west as far as who do you take them
out and if they fall before Dan they
lose their top three protected pick
which kind of makes the season all for
naught basically that will not be
determined until the May seventeenth
lottery in New York but they've got to
get a top to pick in my mind right now
they're slated at least percentage wise
to get a top three pick they have to
have it where else the season was a
total failure period and that I I like
in Kobe I mean he looked like the
Michelin Man with ice all over him last
night and kanika what what what is he
going to get a chance to be Kobe one
more time the rest of this regular
season yeah he keeps saying is going to
play all seven of the remaining games
and you know sundays Boston's coming to
town that's going to be a pretty
emotional night Gary Vitti the longtime
trainer he'll be there going to have his
retirement night obviously you can't
have that on the on the season finale
April 13th Utah at staple center because
that's Kobe's night you know Kobe's he's
been really it's been a rough several
games for him once or seven last night
could not play past the end of the first
quarter of 1 for 11 in Utah the other
night when the lakers lost by 48 the tie
of franchise record for the worst loss
ever in their 68-year history dan I
don't know we might have seen the best
of Kobe you know maybe he if he scores
25 points in one of these games he's
probably gonna have to take
twenty-something shots to get to it
because he is running on fumes right now
great stuff Mike is always thanks for
joining us and have fun the rest of the
regular season how could I not usual is
what's around the next corner right
thank you Mike the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience